welcome to Sophie & Co I'm Sophie
Shepherd not said 40 years own the
groundbreaking music of Pink Floyd still
sounds fresh in the lyrics of Roger
Waters are as relevant as ever how hard
is the balancing act between music and
politics well I'm here in st. Petersburg
to ask the legend himself Roger Waters
musician author activist co-founder of
Pink Floyd and my guest today it's
really great to have you with us today
welcome to our show thank you everyone's
really happy that you're here looking
forward for your tour and I'm looking
for it for a little chat so I'm gonna
start from the eternal question because
you've been pushing the boundaries of
music forever at the same time the
lyrics that you write are always very
powerful so the big question is what is
more powerful the word or the music well
the way the way that I work it they have
equal importance I mean the trick with
with songs and I'm never quite sure
where it comes from but it's to do with
the way the feelings that are in the
lyric of the songs and the ideas that
are in the lyrics of the song somehow
get kicked into a more accessible place
by having to relate to the meter of the
music I don't know it's a kind of
magical thing is I feel a bit like I'm
kind of pulling the wings of a butterfly
even to talk about it because it's sort
of mysterious you know writing song it's
a sort of a mystery how it happens or
why it happens where the connections are
made between the heart and the soul and
the brain and the intellect and the
nature of if one is intellectually
inquisitive about the world that one
lives in and so on and so forth it's
just a way of I don't have been being
alive you get this question a lot in
different forms but I never really cried
grasped an answer for instance if you go
to a Paul McCartney
sorry was a great musician and a friend
of yours from what I gather you forget
about Syria and sanctions for one night
and you have that little space for three
hours to think about love or heartbreak
or I don't know family friendship you
would never be okay with giving your
audience or people just that what is it
about does music always have to be fused
with a certain message or else it makes
less sense and it's not as important no
there's no no there's no has to or
doesn't have to or I think my father was
dead so I never really knew him at all
but my mother gave me a great gift when
I was a child and that was she said that
the only thing that was fundamentally
important to her was to care for other
human beings to empathize with others so
for instance she was a schoolteacher she
had my brother and I to bring up on her
own and she would she was very political
so if she would go to a political
meeting often in the evening she drug us
along with her and we sit there and the
British China Friendship Association or
something I'm beset this is specific and
we would watch grainy movies about the
heroic struggle of the you know of Mount
of Mao and the Long March and that
Chinese people's fighting against the
Japanese and the puppet government and
blah but after the meetings in Cambridge
where I bought up would be in the
Friends Meeting House which is that the
home of the Quakers which a religious
sect Allah I'll never forget what my mum
said to me one day when we were leaving
she said you know where we are you know
and I said yeah yeah well I didn't
really it's a school the Friends Meeting
House right
it's the Quakers there it's a Christian
sect she said as you know I'm an atheist
so I cannot subscribe to their religious
beliefs but they are very very good
people and I thought wow how cool is
that now I still
he is saying it so I guess you're very
much like your mother from what you
described right now I have the house
well me and you very outspoken and you
always say what you think and you're
very adamant to get your message through
and you've been political throughout all
your life from day one of your career
but people now are saying you know maybe
waters should just stick to music they
never really say it before and I wonder
why it has become so pervasive now as
your message change does it become more
acute why are they all of a sudden
realizing that Roger Waters along with
great music is obviously working because
they're asleep because they are the
victims of neo liberalism you know that
Ronald Reagan and Margaret Thatcher
wrote to the world and that has spread
all basically certainly through Western
culture and Western politics and things
and it apart of part of the way that it
works is is to anesthetize people and
almost make it uncomfortable for people
to hear anything real you know this is
this so it's difficult for some people
and I do I get people I mean in America
we'd get people walking out of the show
it's not many maybe four or five out of
20,000 you know but nevertheless of him
but why doesn't he just shut up and play
the music you know and I sometimes speak
to them because I speak to the audience
most places that I play now and
sometimes some I'm a bit playful how
ready are they to hear that cuz Muslim
are like they're just to trip on breathe
for instance rate and then you're
speaking to them like really trying to
get them out of their comfort zone
unfortunately we don't educate ourselves
or our children well enough and and the
reason we don't do that is a well in
America I live in the United States
American the United States of America
they spend nothing on public education
and the reason is in my view
I'm always ready to be wrong about
everything they want to keep the
electorate ignorant and mindless and
unthinking and malleable and pliable and
very open to the use of consumerism and
propaganda to keep them under control to
maintain you know the Orwellian notion
of the sheep and that whatever and
whatever whatever so I'm gonna get to
the Western mainstream because I really
want to hear your views on that but a
little bit about you before we get to
the bigger things when Iraq war was
taking place he said that your songs
from the wall
we're as relevant as ever and now you're
on tour the tour is called us Plus them
that's a song from the dark side and
obviously you feel like it's relevant
today but you know what hasn't really
changed in the last 40 years I mean no
iPhone 135 thousand will ever change the
fact from what we see that people were
killing each other for religion or oil
or gas or money or they're still
continuing to doing today as if they're
doing like 2,000 years ago does it like
discourage you demoralize you what keeps
you driving because you've been out
there for 40 years and all your songs
were relevant then irrelevant now but
things don't really change well that's
true but we have to remember that 40
years is is sort of irrelevant in in
terms of the history of Homo sapiens and
and also in terms of thought in terms of
the way things develop and and the
potential that we have to change systems
you know first of all you really have to
go back to say well I'm glad that I was
born after the Enlightenment if you like
you know I'm glad I'm I'm glad the
French Revolution happened a couple
hundred years ago so that we can have
the depth ratio and the Droid alone is
in our back pocket if we want it I agree
with that that is a good thing this is
something that I can cling to but and
then that dad that puts us in some way
different than the people who would
suggest that I shouldn't be political
rock and roll shows what are you talking
about what should shouldn't be it's none
of your business
and you could not come or you can come
but you can't influence me with an
opinion about something like it's not
your music it's my music it's not your
job it's my job it's my life this is
what I do and it's what I've always done
if you thought you were a fan of Pink
Floyd and you didn't notice that that's
what I did when I was running Pink Floyd
you're an idiot in that but I don't want
to hear life is too short for me to
listen to idiots I'm not interested in
their opinions I'm interested in the
opinions of people who are thoughtful or
caring or something I'll have something
about them that that there are certain
people that you meet you talk to and
it's like reading a great book let's
talk about you and what you believe in
or you're very outspoken about yours you
know you're an avid supporter of the
boycott divestment sanctions movement
you urge colleagues to follow suit
latest example Lana Del Rey there is no
question that when you say things you
believe them and you take full
responsibility for it but how fair is it
to actually you know shame some of your
colleagues into not going to Israel or
you know pressure them to think like you
they don't because you are your own
person and you're completely entitled to
thinking that okay my alternative is to
say nothing I can't say no when civil
society and Palestine has reached out to
the rest of global civil society which
it did in 2004 and and specifically the
PAP hcvl like the cultural work or thing
they reached they specifically reached
out to artists and cultural figures and
academics in the rest of the world and
said we are dying we're dying here
we're dying please help us please do not
go and to Israel and perform if they
offer you an academic accolade or award
please refuse it this is the only way we
can think of now after the two infant
how does Israel's government change
their mind
well pretty sheep look what they're
doing now they're trying now to make BDS
illegal in the United States and in
France and in Germany and to some extent
that because BDS has shown the light on
what they are actually doing but it's
they don't seem to be learning anything
from it at the moment but they are
swaying public opinion all over the
world not by killing those hundred and
fifty kids and in the great March the
return home the protests near the fence
that's around the prison people are
appalled by that people because it's
almost impossible not to be if you see
it yeah you have to sit BDS helps people
see it I help people see it I pass on as
much of it as I can always because it's
so important to me
still there's another side to this story
and that's just regular Israelis some of
them still come to your show they
haven't even know like voted for a
Netanyahu they're not for settlements
how far is it to punish them people tell
me that unfortunately still it's a huge
majority of Israeli Jews believe that
the policies in relation to Gaza and in
relation to the settlements and
relations with building permits normally
a fine they don't sleep problem with it
this is a big big majority of Israelis
maybe not not not Israeli Arabs ooh but
there are only 20% of the population so
that 80% of the 80% there is a
resistance and I know many of them a
friends of mine yeah but it's not huge
numbers we're gonna take a short break
right now and when we're back we'll
continue talking to Roger Waters
legendary musician activist co-founder
of Pink Floyd stay with us
[Music]
and we're back with Roger Waters Roger
your strong opinions about other things
I know that the white helmets at some
point they asked you for your help and
you're like no because you're a weird
organization and the white helmets why
how much approached me twice once was
for a fundraiser in London organized by
the Syria campaign okay and I looked in
it I thought the something who are these
people
and and so I did a fair bit of research
what is it that you see organization
that the Western mainstream doesn't well
I don't a minute Oh what what is it yeah
well um French because they're always
the current idolized in the West for
instance well okay but I'll tell you
just just a couple of things we could be
here all day talking about the white
helmets because that is a very deep
rabbit hole for a star it there is no
evidence to support the idea that it's a
cross roots organization in rebel-held
territories in Syria that grew up from
people who just wanted to go and help
civilians get out of bomb builders no no
evidence to support that so that's one
thing when I made my speech I gave a
little speech in Barcelona because the
other thing is a French guy who supports
the white helmets he goes around the
world climbing tall buildings wearing a
white helmet and he said I want to come
on stage and give a message to the
children of Syria we haven't forgotten
you can I come and I went no you can't
come on stage and say that I mean I'm
sure he's sincere and and whatever but I
explained why this happened it my gig
was on April the 14th this year yeah
this year in Barcelona
on April the 7th it is alleged there was
a chemical attack in duma in syria and a
video appeared with people hosing down
children of
kids would get you know masks on their
faces and blah blah blah and all of that
made by white helmets and the white
helmets sent this video and it went
viral about only I evidence of that
video for governments of the United
States of America or the UK and the
Republic of France all decided to go and
bomb Syria and I've just on the basis of
that I stood up on stage and said I
think I have this this I think it would
be a huge error to go and bomb F fields
in Syria until we know what happened the
United States in the UK and France D
send a hundred cruise missiles to Syria
I don't think they did much damage thank
goodness they didn't kill people but
they did do that and they did and then
the people left and the next day two
journalists went to Robert Fisk who
worked for the independent but a
perfectly reputable English News
broadsheet worst tabloid havoc sleeper
and and also a stranger journalist he
was working for a conservative Christian
TV station from Texas and his name was
Pearson shop and they both extensively
went all over doom but they both went to
the hospital where the video had been
shot and everybody told them the same
story absolutely nobody knew anything
about any chemical attack the doctor
said there was no chemical attack we had
a few people in who'd got dust in their
throats there was not a single death in
Dubai that day nobody nobody was killed
certainly nobody was affected by
chemicals of any kind and so this is two
independent journalists in that and
sending out these reports that were
unequivocal and I believe I believe them
to be true funnily enough the official
you know chemical weapons
spectres went in four or five weeks
later with all their stuff and their
report came out and they said they
couldn't find a single trace of any
nerve agent
they found chlorinated something that I
can't remember how that was phrase which
could be a bag of salt it could be
anything you know but so they did not
sedate the official report is now out
nobody read it it wasn't news you
couldn't see it on CNN because it's not
the narrative that they follow their
narrative is that there was a chemical
attack and the white helmets a wonderful
I just have to say this one more thing
as I said this in Oslo and I will say
whenever this comes out if there is a
grassroots body call the white helmets
of volunteers separate for the people
who actually it started in Istanbul it
wasn't it didn't start Syria was started
by an English soldier in Istanbul but if
that body exists and they and they go
and help people after you know it as sad
or the Russians or somebody else's drop
bombs on them then I I support them
wholeheartedly with every fiber of my
being but all the evidence points to the
fact that that is not the reality I
don't know if you did you did you see
the the documentary that won the Oscar
yes I have I mean have you ever seen
anything so obviously scripted and
carefully shot and put - did that look
like a documentary that come out of a
water that's another thing I won't talk
to you about you're saying carefully
scripted you used it is not their
narrative that's why the report from the
inspectors is not making a mainstream
media in the United States when you say
like you know I'm critical of US
airstrikes for Syria or you say you know
I believe after looking into it that the
white helmets are a shady organization
from what I've got
or like scrape all case is sorry strange
then they say right away that you are a
putting sympathizer that you're aligned
with the Russian authorities crucially
I'm sure if you were and who you are
they just say outright nuts this thing
kind of get be attacked for being on our
it was it someone I don't even know if
you like put in order why is it that
someone that doesn't express an opinion
that's in line with the State Department
is like scarlet letter like branded like
a Russian spy or like a Kremlin
sympathizer as if like you can't think
for yourself well well I mean clearly
clearly the war mongers are doing it
because they want to promote the idea of
having war with Iran first and maybe
Russia's second there's a lot of money
in war and I know that this sounds like
crazy conspiracy theory stuff but it's
not why are they spending six hundred
billion dollars a year going into
foreign countries that are none of their
business and killing brown people and
Muslims why what's it for you know if
you start asking those who put why why
are you doing this is it because you're
scared cuz they can to attack you
because they hate your freedom I mean
the narrative is nonsensical in every
possible way the u.s. narrative yeah and
they'll probably throw me out eventually
if the color I've no idea I've no idea
did you feel that danger I'd feel that
people are trying to silence me I mean
obviously on the BDS issue they've been
trying to silence me they threatened me
as well where would you go well written
Oh what you mean if if I didn't live in
the United
I don't know no I wouldn't go back to
the UK I don't think would you can
Portugal
we're not Russia um well why Russia
country maybe right I've no I've no idea
can I ask you another thing have you
noticed state that they the general line
and the leeway
so that the American officials allow
themselves to have when they come when
it comes to speaking about the Russians
I mean I've just heard this American
politician say Russians are genetically
driven to co-opt and penetrate that's a
quote and I was thinking oh my god like
if any of the Americans special
officials were caught saying that about
Jews are the African Americans that
would be like the end of their career
yeah why is it okay and why is it
allowed to speak about Russians like
that well because because the mainstream
media in the United States of America
have been selling this narrative to the
general public for the last I don't have
four years I would think it goes but how
long do you think it goes back I would
say about four you think it started
started during Obama period it became
really bad during the presidential
campaign and it's gotten even worse
ever since Trump is in office yeah well
that's true I mean I've had when I was
making this diss record I just made this
is the life we really want the guy was
producing the record producing this
record with me started telling me about
how far T how RT was just pure
propaganda nothing but a pack of lies
all that will i watch charity so I've
said that's you can't see a documentary
about fracking on American television
because they weren't they're not
interested in in in in telling you
anything about anything you know it's so
so obvious now that CNN and all the
Americans all of them they're all the
same MSNBC or to Fox and everything in
between
maybe not discovery no maybe that's the
one little piece of TV in the United
States where you can occasionally get a
glimpse of the reality before it's like
to be human per petrest if it is just
just propaganda
suit and and that I still don't know
though why is the whole Russia thing
I've said this to audiences as well I
said there's some time in you know other
countries women in America since you
have you any idea who the Russians are
have you ever met a Russian person I
said because I've met many Russians and
I don't not saying I know many Russians
very well but I do know this the Russian
people gave up twenty million lives in
the second world war to save you from
the Nazis and you want to go around with
a stick and poke at them are you insane
you have no idea what you're talking
about and also you know nothing about
the country or the people who ever
it's just finger pointing why won't you
work for office because I have important
things to do okay along those important
things thanks a lot for talking to us
and stay tuned on RT okay because I like
you watching us I will good luck with
everything
hey thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you